there was the most vile reaction that
I've seen to the shooting in Nashville
it was from someone who's appeared on
this show actually he's a liberal but
he's appeared on this show and it's it's
just so hideous but and I bring it up
not even just to
castigate this guy but but to show you
how wrong the the libs thinking is how
pervasive this kind of vile thinking is
but also how wrong it is
uh David packman
tweeted Out quote very surprising that
there would be a mass shooting at a
Christian School given that lack of
prayer is often blamed for these
horrible events is it possible they
weren't praying enough or correctly
despite being a Christian School
that that is the most vile tweet I've
ever read
and Twitter is a cesspool
for the most vile kinds of speech you
can imagine
if you have any kind of public profile
at all you've seen you've seen plenty of
vile stuff directed at you or you
but that is the single most vile tweet I
have ever read
he ended up deleting it but he didn't
apologize
in fact he played the victim he said all
right too many anti-semitic attacks and
threats to my family I've delete the
tweet
sorry why that's
one no one saw any of these alleged
anti-semitic attacks or what a what a
joker
how pathetic so I won't even apologize I
was totally right yeah I'm gonna make
fun of these these murdered kids
I'm going to make fun of them for being
Christian haha you idiot Christians yeah
that'll teach you to be Christian
yeah but I'll delete the Tweet anyway I
don't want to deal with you people
anymore that's what he's saying so
really
just very little leaves me
without much to say uh this does one
thing I would have to say about it
though is
his premise is wrong
he's saying that
lack of prayer is often blamed for these
horrible events when has that ever
occurred
I've never once heard from anybody other
than him
that lack of Prayer
is the cause of shootings or any other
kind of evil or suffering
no what happens is after bad things
happen
compassionate people
people with a
even somewhat clear understanding of
reality will say oh I'm praying for you
I'm sending you I I'm thinking of you
and I'm praying for you
and then Libs will
scream and yell at them for it or make
fun of them for it so yeah thoughts and
prayers that's all yes do you keep your
thoughts in prayers and shove it okay
what are you offering I'm offering
thoughts and prayers what are you
offering you're just offering invective
and bile and you're mocking little kids
for being Christians and being murdered
what are you offering we're offering gun
control laws the gun none of the gun
control laws have ever worked you've
passed plenty of gun control laws they
haven't done anything
well we're offering anger oh thanks oh
thank you that's that's what we have a
shortage of is anger oh your anger is so
comforting
what are you offering well we're
offering uh cruel jokes about murdered
children and Christians oh cool thanks I
think I'll stick with thoughts and
prayers if you are
against thoughts and prayers after a
tragedy
that's a pretty good sign you're on the
wrong side
there wasn't sufficient prayer no
Christian believes that
it Reigns on the just and the unjust
alike bad things happen to good people
that's
one of the most basic problems that
anyone who is given even two seconds of
thought to morality and religion has
considered and these people haven't even
gotten that far you know it's often
pointed out that the libs who are
pushing gun control know the least about
guns they don't know how any of the guns
work they don't know anything about the
history of guns they don't know anything
about the effects of gun control laws
they don't know anything about the
history of the Second Amendment they
just don't know anything about anything
but they're the ones who are
pontificating and and attempting to
regulate these things well certainly the
same is true of thoughts and prayers
these people have never given one second
of thought to thoughts and prayers and
the meaning of prayer and the meaning of
suffering and why good things happen to
good people theodicy and more broadly
theology or any of it all they've got to
offer is bile and poison absolutely
disgusting stuff and they are pushing it
there was a release from the trans
resistance Network
this came out on the school shooting
they said it's the trans resistance
Network's been notified of this shooting
it's not our policy to engage publicly
with the news media we believe this
calls from for a thoughtful response
from our Collective we point out that
today's incident in Nashville Tennessee
is not one tragedy but two
I think you know where this is going
the first tragedy today is the loss of
life of three children and adults we
extend our deepest sympathies we mourn
with you the second and more complex
tragedy is that Aiden or Aubry Hale who
felt he had no uh he it's a she had no
other effective way to be seen than to
lash out by taking the life of others
and by consequence himself really
herself
that's that's the real tragedy
she just she just felt she had no other
option
you know and why did she feel that way
it's because of those Christians yeah
this is the same this is essentially the
same thing David Pacman made a joke
about it and the trans resistance
network is saying it with a straight
face yeah these Christians they're just
they're just so wrong they're so wrong
that they're bringing this upon
themselves
yeah
yeah that's the real tragedy is that you
guys just didn't get on the program with
the transgender ideology
this statement tells me it goes on and
it gets worse and I just won't read it
but this tells me though is I think this
is the
the final collapse
of
one of the
dishonest arguments we hear from the
libs on the transgender ideology issue
which is who cares
oh who cares what do you care this
doesn't affect you
this does this isn't a big deal just
Live and Let Live who cares
who cares
um
these people care
these people care enough
that they would blame
Christians and conservatives and
Society broadly for forcing
a transgender identifying person to
shoot up a Christian School full of
little kids
like an abusive husband who says to his
wife why did you make me do that
why did you make this shooter do that
goes how many parents one two three four
five say like 11 or 12 paragraphs on
them
this is a pretty pervasive belief if
only if only you had just hadn't been so
damn Christian you know if only you guys
had just hadn't been so hateful
we wouldn't have to do this we'd have to
fight back wouldn't have to resist
wouldn't have to have a day of Vengeance
vengeance
but who cares
who cares I think they care and I think
they care a lot and if
if one does not have the clarity and
courage to stand against this ideology
that is about a lot more than just some
confused people
it's about
using confused people weaponizing
confused people to upend an entire
political order and to exalt the most
disgusting and depraved and wicked sorts
of people in society the kind of people
who would who would write these tweets
and suppressing and bullying into
silence ordinary people who hold
ordinary true traditional beliefs
that's what it's about
that's what it's always been about
I think people are beginning to see that
a little bit more
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it if you are not a
member go to dailywire.com
use code knows to check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign